hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another high definition video with yet
another youtube update and yes i'd like
to keep you guys up to date on track
with the youtube uh youtube's more
subtle features that aren't as obvious
to you and one of them which has
recently risen is not only changes to
the youtube video watch page but as you
can see by the title sharing youtube
comments now if we scroll down yes there
are a few changes to the youtube watch
page as you can see here you can
actually see how many likes and dislikes
a video has instead of a chart before
you actually like the video which you of
course should like this most recent
video and then of course over on the
right hand side instead of seeing that
little chart where you could like or
dislike and see how many likes there
were by hovering you can actually click
this now to view the youtube video
statistics and i like this the way it is
the chart is very intuitive and you know
to click that to view statistics
but the main point in this video is
actually
comment sharing so if you go you don't
actually have to view all comments to do
this but as you saw when i threw it up
on twitter we can hover over a comment
on the right there's a share button and
it didn't work for a little bit but it
finally seems to work so you can go
ahead and try to find this exact comment
and share it like i'm doing now so
there's a share button that just popped
up you hit that share button and it
doesn't actually work yet as of right
now anyway on the all comments page so
no matter how many times i've clicked
any of these comments as a matter of
fact i can't seem to get them to share
however on the video watch page for this
ikea audio hdr 7 review if i just find a
comment this is the test comment for
youtube video sharing i can hit the
share button and link to this comment on
facebook myspace what what's my space
whatever facebook myspace and twitter so
if i go ahead and click the twitter
button it'll bring me a separate window
where i can see uh this comment exactly
check out this comment in quotes at
t.c.o shortened via youtube and i'll
tweet this
and you guys will go ahead and see that
this has been tweeted signed in as mkbhd
and you can go ahead and follow me there
on twitter i'm not going to put it on
facebook but i'll go ahead and i mean
you guys know it'll work the same way on
facebook myspace don't even ask me i
don't know so you can go ahead and exit
out of that if you hit it by accident
but that's really basically it so if you
just get such a kick out of a comment
that you feel the need to share a
comment on a social network that is now
how you do it so you guys are now free
and inspired to leave amazing comments
on my videos so until next time this has
been mkbhd just with a quick update
video about youtube and until next time
i'll talk to you later peace